as many parents know buying the best
sports equipment for your child has
become a sport in itself in fact it's a
15 and a half billion dollar industry
with some family spending as much as 10
percent of their incomes on sports
activities when you include equipment
training and travel but one big expense
in the sport of swimming is now leading
to a national backlash meg Oliver has
the story in a graceful sport consumed
with speed swimmers are always looking
for that extra edge 15 year old Malia
Mills believes her high-tech swimsuit
shaved two seconds off her time at
Junior Nationals an eternity in swimming
Matt Farrell is with USA Swimming he's
concerned swimmers younger than 12 are
relying more on technology and less on
training what's the pressure like among
parents to buy these high-tech suits
there's just a natural competitiveness
in youth sports and any activity it just
creates a parental arms race that
competition became so intense swim
chapters around the country started
banning high-tech suits for younger
swimmers a few months ago Southern
California led the way followed by
Arkansas Maine New England New Jersey
and South Carolina high tech suits
actually repel water absolutely
in August USA Swimming hired independent
consultants to Issac to determine if a
nationwide ban is needed to level the
length when the water is on it comes
with tough it runs right off and you
know you can see completely dry yes so
how much faster can that make you in the
water it reduces the drag it's just not
absorbing the water and when it doesn't
absorb the water it doesn't change your
density of the suit while you're
swimming if a 12 year old girl wears one
of these high-tech suits are they going
to swim like Katie ledecky
what makes the summer good is of course
talent their physical makeup but it's
really the technique it's the training
part of the debate also involves money
the suits range in price from one
hundred to five hundred forty nine
dollars parents like Laura Bunin held
out for as long as she could it would
feel wrong to send her to a big
competition where everyone else was
wearing the suit and she isn't so you
felt pressure to buy one yes very much
so we asked a group of young swimmers
about a possible ban I don't wanna like
waste it do you think you can swim just
as fast without your tech suit I don't
know it's that psychological component
that some coaches like Patrick Collins
say instills a false sense of speed a
lot of them look at it like some magic
pill but years from now I'd rather a kid
say hey it was me and all the hard work
that I put into the sport rather than
just the suit that got them to shave
that time for CBS this morning Saturday
Meg Oliver Indianapolis okay between the
thousand-dollar fingerlings and the $500
swimsuit it's getting expensive devil
kid isn't a second job just to raise
this kid five hundred and fifty dollars
for us I mean believable yeah